Danny is with us in Orlando hi Danny how
are you hey there hi Dave hey how can I
help today sir well I got to tell you
first that I've read your books
I brought my daughters to your live
event in Orlando I've even offered to
buy your program your Financial Peace
University for my staff Wow so I really
believed you're welcome I really believe
in the message that you're giving thank
you and I've got you're welcome I've got
kind of a small problem I just need a
little financial marital counseling
wanted on an issue okay I have a
wonderful wife you couldn't ask for a
nicer person but she thinks that I
should divest myself of of a particular
car that I own it's my midlife crisis
sports car but I really don't drive very
much oh but she thinks is not practical
to have this car sitting in my garage
because I wouldn't what is it this is a
1992 Acura NSX sports car I've had it
from since it was new 25 years ago okay
you bought it brand-new
okay brand-new before her ah well before
her yeah and yeah and so what is the car
worth I probably thirty five forty
thousand dollars now Wow it's done well
okay well I paid 50 for it but that's 25
years ago
yeah I'm still shocked event gone down
more than that um the okay and so what
is your household income Oh probably 250
a year and what is your net worth
um pushing close to three million okay
um well I don't know why you would sell
a car it's absolutely no you should keep
that car don't worry I should keep that
car Dave yeah listen hey let me tell you
how I might let me tell ya let me tell
you how I made the decision okay here's
how you make the decision the car is a
she's exactly right it's completely
impractical it's a toy yeah okay it's
emotional but this is like asking her to
sell her wedding ring and she doesn't
realize that uh-huh
I would never ask you to do
right and it's a car you've had for 25
years it's card actually means something
to you number one number two it is a
ultra small percentage of your net worth
if you had called me up and said I make
$60,000 a year we're broken in debt and
I love my car I would have said when
little boys sell your car but you're not
broken until you're worth three freakin
million dollars you could drive this car
off a cliff and it you would even notice
it doesn't change your net worth one
iota okay it's such a small percentage
of your world it doesn't matter it's
like most people buying a biscuit okay
and so it doesn't matter it just sits
there now why you want to keep it I tell
you I got my co-pilot here
yeah I can tell you understand
so I I am afraid that this would be one
of those cars that if you sell it ten
years from now you'll feed on TV you
know at the auction even care about I
don't I don't even care about that the
point is it's a toy you like it yes and
it's so freaking small a percentage of
your world it does not matter yes if
it's if it becomes worth a dollar
tomorrow it doesn't matter it doesn't
change their life that's great you know
with a very thats how you justify a toy
you do it on ratios you know and that's
like this friend of mine just bought a
jet he just bought a ten million dollar
jet uh-huh okay that's a nice jet very
but he's worth two billion ten million
as a percentage of two billion uh-huh
that's like this car for you or like
most people buying a biscuit it doesn't
affect his world ten million in my world
I grew up Manny I kind of see ten
million dollars this is what we call a
lot of money you know a $40,000 car
sitting in your garage is what we call a
lot of money you know I grew up that way
but it's a small percentage of your
world and that's how you can tell if
you're out of whack or not with this
it's just a toy it's just a toy it's
just an expensive toy and so if she
wants to renovate the dining room and
than $40,000 it's that you can afford it
shut up yeah do it yeah and if you want
to go on a vacation and spend $10,000 on
a cruise you can afford it make 250,000
freaking dollars a year and you're
debt-free and you're worth three million
dollars you have done it man you work
like no one else and you enjoy some of
it I want you to be outrageously
generous on the other hand and I want
you to be wise and continually investing
and I don't want you to go buy something
that costs a million dollars it's a toy
that would be out of line in your world
yes sir but this is a small percentage
of your world and so that's why you win
the argument she is correct that it is a
useless impractical thing but so what
saves you - man so what it's useless no
she wins that part of the argument I get
that she doesn't get it I don't blame
her for that part she's actually using
common sense but it's a small it's lint
on the lint brush you know yes good and
that's the way you look at it and so you
know I've had to learn to work without
working with wealthy people because I
couldn't emotionally grasp and I caught
myself saying stupid but stuff like no
one could ever spend that much for a dot
dot guy and all that is is poor man
thinking that's all that is that's loser
talk no one should ever have a house
that big no one should ever have two
houses no one should ever have a
$10,000,000 jet no one should ever have
a $40,000 - I said stupid stuff like
that and I had to quit doing that
because it when I look up and I realized
for some people ratio-wise it's lint on
a lint brush and as if that's what it is
then you can afford to do it if you can
you know burn it in the backyard as on
in next week's bonfire and it doesn't
change your life then you can afford to
quote waste the money unquote for
enjoyment purposes and that's fine
that's why you work but also be generous
be giving be helping others with this
wonderful net worth in this wonderful
income have that as part of the mix I'm
sure you are you told me you're sending
your employees through a financial piece
and you're doing other stuff I'm sure
your church or whatever that kind of
stuff
all great but it just doesn't matter and
it's just like me I can look at my
buddies ten million dollar jet it meant
a dadgum incredible it's a sweet ride
I'll just tell you man but it's a small
percentage of his two billion dollar
world a billion y'all think about that
with me that's a thousand million that's
not thousand million he's got two
thousand million and out of two thousand
million he spent ten of them you see
what I mean as a ratio that's not much
that's like having two hundred thousand
dollars and spending ten thousand bucks
think about it it didn't change your
life right you'll be alright
but you know you didn't feel it hardly
it doesn't he doesn't move the needle
and that's not being wasteful at that
stage of the game so hold on Danny
that's a wonderful question made my day
to get to answer it and I'm glad the
copilot was there it was a fun
discussion hang on I'm going to send you
a copy of the book the legacy journey
you you to read that you will enjoy it
it's where we discuss wealth all my
other books are about money
the legacy journey is about wealth
wealth is different than money money
creates wealth but wealth is different
than money is a different subject n is a
different subject biblically if you're
for those of us that are Christians
those of us other people of faith the
Bible addresses wealth differently than
addresses money money is transactional
money is the thing we use to buy food
for our kids and that counting wealth is
different
wealth has more problems with it but
more opportunities with it and one of
the things is is that you are encouraged
scripturally to enjoy the fruits of your
labor not to be a hedonist and not to be
braggadocious but you know enjoy it and
i've got some nice cars i've got a
classic car drove it set and drove his
sunday out in the sun my wife and i put
the top down drove a 1960 Corvette i
bought the other day
it's a sweetie looks like a Marilyn
Monroe car right sure now driving around
Insurance got a little hat on I'm not
driving miss daisy' you know it was a
lot of fun
two old people riding around this cool
car it was neat and hey it's a small
percentage of my
girl a small percentage of my world a
very small percentage of my world so hey
thanks for listening hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]